on this week's show the successful
habits of a property investor in the
news war has been declared on by to let
landlords given renters option to buy
and we're gonna be answering all your
property related questions
welcome to the property investors
podcast thanks so much for tuning in
make sure you subscribe so you never
miss an upload you can catch us on Apple
podcasts Spotify and YouTube enjoy this
week's show and don't forget to share it
with all your friends
I always leave I'm Alistair Cunningham
and welcome to this week's property
investors podcast we're gonna be looking
at the successful habits for a property
investor and also pretty crazy news yeah
war come war has been declared that
we'll be discussing that like in intense
intense so how are you my friend you had
a good week phenomenal I'm really good
you've been lost my voice my voice is
really a bit it's just a sudden recovery
at the minute so it's a bit so that's
good just not great for a podcast is it
no no no but it's on its way back it's
not too bad it's not totally lost are
you there like that will probably be a
much better show either
I reckon that can you imagine that'd be
amazing yeah we would be over there I'm
just I could just keep talking it
wouldn't be a problem at all keep two
people happy I've just got back from
Germany I was on our sort of yeah I was
on a personal development sort of
speaking course come join me for six
days so that was phenomenal like it was
absolutely phenomenal where in Germany
was it Frankfurt and what facts did you
tell me about Frankfurt when he got back
that it's got a lot of history no a lot
of heritage what was the fact you told
me about Frank did you feel me and
telling me what was the fact that you
talked you could have sliced it in right
now you mean awesome but don't worry
what was the fire ah okay it's got it's
got one of the most successful and
largest European airports so we're gonna
me we were looking today at the
successful habits of a property investor
and it's what made me sore thing this
actually is interesting samuel posted on
the Facebook group the other day what's
the difference between a winner and a
loser then or do you see that post yeah
yeah and I commented and this and I said
they have different habits yes the do
you yeah and I know I think that is the
primary difference in success person and
an unsuccessful person is they've got
different habits yeah I believe that and
the thing is is that most people that
wanna be a property investor obviously
education is really really important you
need to know what you're doing right but
even more important than education or at
least as important as education it's
actually doing it doing it yeah there's
no point there's no point being fully
educated know exactly what's going to do
if you're not going to go and do it
would you I completely listen right and
I'm all for educating I'm all for
reading I'm all for doing lots of stuff
but you could all you end up being as a
stuffed monkey so you need to get out
there and actually implement mmm and one
of the biggest failures I see in people
that want to do be successful is failure
to take action is failure to implement
and instead it's bad habits they've got
into now what happens is is they they go
to a course or the read a book and
they're motivated for a couple of days
then they just fall back into their bad
habits they don't stick to them good
habits that they learn on these personal
development courses or they layer on at
the crash course or they learn at DFA
they don't stick to them and then then
they start the the worst thing I see
people when they're unsuccessful is they
then blame others they blame other
people they played in the course to
blame the they blame the the
surroundings they blame other people
they blame their state agent but one the
most successful things I think anybody
can do to be successful is take
responsibility be responsible for your
business mind your own business
yeah and take responsibility so I think
the the first good habit that you guys
need to be writing down is take
responsibility for yourself it's nobody
else's fault that you're unsuccessful if
you're unsuccessful it's your fault I
genuinely believe that I fault that you
for not not everybody but ya know if
you're unsuccessful and you're just
looking to blame somebody then you'll
never be successful it's that simple
is that simple so well yeah bang on so
what we kind of wanted to talk about
today was first of all we thought we'd
share some of our good habit yes that
were for us but more importantly than
that is you probably know you probably
know the stuff that you need to be doing
in order to be successful so we're going
to talk about how you actually do that
it's the same as you know everyone knows
in order to get fit they need to go to
the gym mhm
right and then some people set that as a
new habit especially in January is
resolution yeah new me and then for the
first two weeks of January but or the
first week maybe it's like yeah at the
gym and then what happens is by the end
of January
no one goes anymore that's because
they've fallen back into the bad habit
yeah so how do you create how do you get
rid of a bad habit and replace it with a
good habit well first of all I thought
that was a very good place to start is
by replacing habits so finding something
that you did so let's say for example
you've got a bad habit of every time you
get home from work you just slim em at
the TV and watch the TV yeah so rather
than just now I'm not gonna watch TV you
want it rather than focusing on that you
want to think about okay so what can I
do instead and then that can become my
new good habit yeah and I always find
you know they say don't they what you
focus on expands hmm and if you're
focusing on the negative of the other of
there's much better to focus on the on
the positive it's much focus on taking
action rather than the non taking of
action does do you agree with that
hundred plan yeah so I found the same
with with anything so if you're if you
wanted to lose weight
focus on the foods that you can eat not
ones not the food you can't eat I'm
reading the miracle morning I'm not
reading I'm listening to it and I'm at
the point in a minute where it talks
about getting out of bed early and it's
saying that if if you need if you keep
telling your body you need 10 hours a
night or six or eight hours a night and
then you go to bed at midnight knowing
you've got to get up at six you're
telling your body that you're going to
be tired you're like oh so exhausted I'm
going to be exhausted but if you go to
body saying I can't wait to wake up
because six hours is enough you wake up
a different attitude in a different
energy so it again
about habits I think it's about habits
and it's about its I think also it's
really important on this course of his
come back from they talk a lot they
spend a lot of time talking about Court
of Honor and I think everyone should
have a cord of honor for themselves and
with regards to everything in their life
so just a set of rules that you stick to
so if you say you're gonna do something
do it if you say you're gonna be
somewhere be there if you say you're
gonna have stop and you die start buying
you that if you say you're gonna learn
to do property investing learn to the
property invest in yeah and just have a
set of rules that you stick to and and
it's very clear to have a really good
understanding of them rules so don't
just say I'm going to sort of lay on a
new skill what are you going to learn
and how you gonna implement it and the
Court of Honor is a fantastic thing and
I'm rewrite and I'm actually writing
code of honors now because I've thought
I've always had Court of honors but the
beam in my head now what I think I'm
gonna do now is I'm going to actually
write them and document it and frame it
so that it's there with very clear
understandings
let's just so I can get myself back into
good habits that's really good
so what first thing I talk about is the
stages of habits because why is it that
we're so pumped so excited to go to the
gym or whatever it is for the foot for a
first and then it turns into before we
create as a habit it turns to crap yeah
so experts tell us that it takes about
21 days to create a new habit 21 days do
something bank ah it's it's it's gonna
be different for everyone a bit so it's
not gonna be a it's not gonna be an
exact science yeah I like to work of a
little bit longer and I think in miracle
morning he says similar he like it's not
more like 30 days that's why the
American one for 30 days it's like okay
cool because then that way I know I'm
sort of safe on well over anyone and our
for me I found there's four stages to a
new habit right and and I've used fate
just to help you remember it so FTE fate
so the first stage is fun when you first
start doing it you're pumped about it
you said you're thinking about a change
you're like yeah this is awesome it's
really fun wherever that we going to the
gym whether it be getting up really
early whether it be listening to new
audiobooks it's fun right but soon that
fun the earth tones into the
which is agony right so it's gone from
like oh this is really fun too this is
horrible
even if it's something small you detest
and you hate doing it solo whether I won
one of my habits now every time I'm
traveling with I'm on the train we're on
walking pretty much to me so I'm on my
own pretty much if I'm walking traveling
on the train driving a car occasionally
X months wherever it is I'm doing
I always listen to audiobooks yeah right
but not just like stories nonfiction oh
yeah factual HEDIS the helping personal
development businessman sales whatever
it is so what's gonna help me grow and
I'm quite and I've got in the habit of
wanting to grow and improve myself all
the time as person which if it's great
habit yeah right but it took me a while
of doing that again
to get into it to me it took me a while
but I didn't almost intentionally I kind
of slipped into that which is great but
if at first it was is is awesome then it
was like this boring man I'm going to
just said you go for the boring stages
are absolutely or they just said to
Russell before we started filming I was
listening to an audio but yes they
driving up to our training course I was
running and it was the most I had to
turn off because it was so boring it was
putting me to sleep and I was I just had
to turn off so there's a time and a
place for listen to audiobooks
I prefer listen to audiobooks first
thing in the morning or in the morning
yeah and afternoon I tend not to attend
to listen to music but what you need to
do is you to get yourself into a
situation where okay Larry might be you
want I'm not saying listen to music is
wrong oh I'm not saying that but let's
say every morning you want to listen to
how long how long a day thirty minutes
right so you might do it okay today then
on day three or day for yep that's so
rather sleep you've got your little
voice now I don't need it every day this
is stupid you know this is this is just
boring man this is and then what happens
is you stop doing it yes you start full
of excitement you go through your agony
boring it was exercise it's certainly
agony or getting up early it's easier to
fall back into your routine into yeah
like you never got anywhere in life
easily so everything in life comes with
hard work or hard graft or so
thing the the success successful people
out there that just locked into it are
few and far between so if you want
something you're gonna have to make a
serious change and I think thing I'm not
sure who it was it said this I believe
it was Henry Ford he said the definition
definition of insanity is doing the same
thing and expecting different results so
you have to do different things if you
want different results so definitely for
but it wasn't it was somebody else out
on her hand before it says something
else but say that guys who said let me
know tumblr who said they will know
though I want to create am I don't like
seeing phrases about credit and the
right people so well let me know I just
did that but whoever said that that's
from you do you know if you want to find
out if you want to find out just say
quote from me and then say and then
everyone but I never take on and he just
creates Henry Ford right so you've got
your fun stage right the other day so
then you got your agony stage that lasts
about I find about a week okay he's
agony holidays then I've put ten days
because it's listen it's not an exact
science like I said yeah ten days a week
whatever right then after agony its T FA
T which is it's tough yeah right it's
not agony anymore you kind of getting
used to it I was like bearable it's
bearable it's like yeah this is this is
this is tough this so it's a bit like
when I'm listening to you when I'm here
on the podcast with you I find it tough
but bearable but you know what even the
podcast is a habit is its habit it is
because we've said we're gonna do a
podcast every week
now the first couple times we did it
yeah it was like ah this is also we made
and then you like arms doing think of
ideas I'm going to remember that little
phase yeah the agony phase yeah when I
realize doesn't have to work with you
every week and it was just like oh this
is painful this is agony and then after
after after a few like become just
cleared off yeah bear alway was just
tough I'm still waiting for the enjoy
story it's not yeah yeah and it's been
about a year huh habit is if the habit
stop in the face but then the final
stage is is enjoyable and you start
getting
we ought we are joking easing but course
we want a stripe so there's there's your
steps F a TEM what you've got to do is
you've got to remember that it's if you
know if you do something for 30 days
yeah it will become a habit and it will
become enjoyable I know it will right
then it gives you the perseverance to
get to get through because we're in
those agony the thing is when you're in
the agony stage this this is the sort of
thing you're thinking you thinking this
just isn't worth it yeah it's not yeah I
just I don't want to be fit that bad you
know I was gonna say weight loss is
probably the biggest one that people
break because like everyone is like a
personal trainer told me it's taken me
so I'm I'm in my mid-thirties and it's
taken 35 years to get to build did you
start when you were 3
[Laughter]
right is taken like a long time to get
the body I've got how can I expect to
lose it in two weeks do you know I mean
how can I expect to lose a little weight
in two weeks and it becomes when you're
when you're at the agony stage you just
you don't see much weight falling off
and when then you went to the tough
stage you're not seeing much weight come
off and then you think I just can't be
bothered with it's just not worth it
yeah it's persistence and persistence
and persistence you want to be fit and
healthy in a week that you want to look
that's the problem
everyone wants to be fitting up in a
week with a six-pack and but you ever
anything worth doing takes Jim Rohn says
doesn't it it's simple to do it's also
easier not to it's easier yes easy it's
simple not to do so I think it's a case
of so she what which to sum up and like
five things what other thing that
they're five good habits to get into
four five good habits yeah alright so I
would say number one no one with reading
books and listening to personal
development personal development you
know watching Samuel youtube videos
watching whatever it might be the other
thing I would say as well it's doing it
every day yeah right don't take this
because it's a Sunday mm-hmm or take it
out cuz a Saturday do it every single
day that you know I find that bizarre
right no I just to go off a lot but yeah
I find that quite bizarre that people
say about like taking Taylor
like Sunday's a rest day Saturday's out
like we can't hear like did you go home
or anything hey it's the weekend no I've
never had that feeling I've never had
that Friday feeling so to speak and true
story mind you we've both got kids sir
true story I go beta Monday stuff
arrestee true story in our office we've
actually banned the phrase Friday
feeling I'm not nobody's allowed to say
a word Friday feeling because it's not
we if you love what you do then I love
work I love doing what we do so to me
every day is I'm doing something every
day and it will develop me and grow me
and and helped me become more and more
successful yeah and I think that's a
good habit to get into I do I think when
you picking a habit so I mean good you
should pick something that's easy you
can look at it and go like I've done
I've started new habits see the thing is
as well is it was almost a bodega like
for sort of key areas of your life right
you've got you know business yeah you've
got your relationships spiritual and
relationships friends family that sort
of stuff and most people I've got good
most accessible you've got good habits
in May maybe one or two of the areas
yeah it's a like way for example that I
say health no you didn't all right maybe
it's five so you got health
mmm business relationships yeah
spirituality well there's four but you
said to relationship she said
relationships for your your
relationships in general yeah so so for
me at health I've never really I've
never been really good if I'm a little
bit overweight and why cuz doesn't make
any money well yeah probably so but now
I'm I'm trying to do I'm doing this
stuff on myself in other areas life
we're not doing as well so business man
I've cracked it I got the habits I'm
doing great
property investing I do business I've
got it man I know I'm doing I've got I'm
in the right habits but over areas I'm
trying to I'm trying to work on so I'm
doing this stuff so this this is as much
for us as it is for you guys
so number one is and what is is develop
yep yeah so reading what we do
videos and make it easy yeah it's not so
easy this morning I got the underground
to work my audio became 15 20 minutes
listen to all of it every day I do 2
hours a day
yeah I did more actually because I did
the miracle morning as well but I do 2
hours a day cuz I've got an hour to work
and an hour back from work yeah some of
that's what walking and stuff also if
you can like it so yeah anyway so number
one your personal development make sure
you always developing yourself that's a
very good habit to get into number two
as a property investor I think we'd get
property investor and business in
general ok number two I would say
persistence but in what so you've got to
put you've got to be consistent and
persistent you cannot give up at the
first hurdle so you've got to
consistently be working on but what is
your habit which will happen what might
so for instance as a property investor
and you have to consistently be going to
your area and mean and keeping in touch
with the people you meet in that area so
if you've got relationships at estate
agents you need to be consistently
keeping in touch with them so don't use
ignore dominant every six month message
them I would literally be going to see
them once a month or and just phoning
them every week or your power team in
that area so you're letting agency
stages that you're looking to buy deal's
off
just speak them on a regular basis okay
you get out there get seeding meeting
people and just be consistent with with
that with the meeting of people it's so
important because people properties
people business you'll get more deals by
knowing the right people than you will
by looking on online shall we say yeah
yeah you must be consistent with getting
out there and that includes networking
and get into networking events like and
I see so many people were they ask me
how I find so many investors and I'm
like because when I first started in
this game and I'm not gonna be
completely honest I don't really network
now because I'm just far too busy but
when I first started not true
I still network but not it not hold on
so I still network a lot actually you're
right it's not true I still networking
like I just don't network the way I used
to network yeah so when you first start
that you've got all these networking
events all up and down the country like
pin pick wherever there's laws of
another country and just consistently go
to them
be there every month make it a habit to
go there the second Tuesday every month
7 p.m. to this hotel and go to that
networking event because you get lots of
deals and you'll meet lots of
connections you'll get JV partners and I
say to people that they say how do you
get so many investors and I met because
I network like crazy and then they see
how I struggled one of the things and I
said well how many do you go to and I
went to that one one two went to that
one ones and I'm like yeah but once
isn't enough you have to go there 12
times just to say it's the exact same
that I'm going the habit of it they've
got on their goober times it's been fun
and it gets to the boring stage or the
agony stage and they're like no it's not
okay I'm gonna go to I'm gonna commit
I'm gonna go to this I'm gonna go to
Penn I'd only go to one a week for a
year I do a good thing to do to help
with that habit is Buch and pay for the
whole year upfront because then you've
paid for it you're committed yeah yeah
that way so yeah number three so number
three is so every single morning when
you wake up instead of scrolling through
social media Instagram Facebook scroll
through right move
look at right move look for your
property criterias in your area and
actually look at properties instead of
looking at what your neighbor's cat was
doing last night it is so much more
beneficial for you and it's gonna get
you a lot further than looking at
Instagram simple as that number four
before I mean we could do loads I mean
number four I know what number four is
go on number four is actually book
viewings and go and see the properties
because a lot of people I know they look
through Rightmove and online forever
they build lovely spreadsheets and got
all these properties but they never
actually go and view them now I've got
many deals by actually going to view
them speaking to the agent and I've got
no money down deals because of it so
number three is get off social media and
actually look at right-moving
other places online and find the deals
number four is get your ass out of bed
and get out there and start looking at
these deals and well very big happen
number four link to number four right
going Arun the deals yes
beyond tae-yeon I was just gonna say be
on time because that's a habit yeah
being on you know it's people are on
time always on time yeah the people are
five minutes like or always five minutes
late and the people that just don't and
link to being on time see or me there's
loads we could go out but to be on time
is do
you say you're going to do yeah that is
also it's a habit
- what severe that cool of honor one of
our code of honors is do what you say
yeah say what you mean yeah and bees you
see absolutely that's why should always
turn up time with their state agents cuz
if you say you're gonna be there on time
be there on time it's funny because I
mean I think he talked about it on
miracle morning think I'm not sure but
he said like when you when you hit the
snooze button
yeah I'm there now you're there now
that's my own so when you you say to
yourself I am gonna get up at five fifty
five yeah right along there's up 555
you're like forget that snooze what
you're doing right there's a small thing
little thing but you're setting the
habit of I say I'm gonna do something
and then when I actually don't want to
do it
I don't they just break your rules yeah
I say we do it but I don't I hit the
snooze even though I was gonna get now
if you plan long any of it six to set
your app 555 so you could hit the snooze
have five bits and then get up at six
that's fine but if you say I'm gonna get
up at five fifty five and then you hit
the snooze you're creating a habit of
not doing what you say you're gonna do
you know and that is a terrible habit
that is because then it relates
throughout all of your life
yeah is this school that it's the small
if you start with the small things Guam
do you know what it's like am at the
crash course we have rules that if you
come back after a break you're not
normally allowed into the venue because
it's just not it's not fair to the
people that have made the effort to get
back on time and we all say this it's
always the same people that are coming
back on late every break they come back
late and then they kick off in the moon
and the thing is that's how they are in
real life they're always late so just be
on time and that leads us on to number
five can I can I add one can I add one
insert can we have six yeah because this
is five what was number five five number
five is bring energy so somewhat person
with the most energy yet wins and if you
haven't got that one of the ways to
build energy is to exercise so you have
it my bear count on with exercise every
day so that I can come with energy yeah
absolutely
I think energy is so important when you
go into any business meeting who you're
going to who you gonna deal with the
person is a bit more cheery a bit more
happy a bit more high energy
the person that sat there I've been a
bit Moody you know we're not going to
deal with a MIDI person or never gonna
be with them and this last one number
six this is my most valuable habit yeah
right and this habit will add on average
11 years to your life well and make you
happier okay and feel better throughout
your life as well it's being positive
positive with that massive they agree
with that a bit if you and it is a habit
yeah it is it being positive so choice
it's a choice isn't it as you can choose
to be negative or positive
I completely agree with that because I
used to be quite negative about
everything and I know some people that
do things like they wear like a corn out
of seven as well it's kind of linked so
we'll include it as this but be grateful
yeah being grateful all my days such a
difference to life been grateful but
what will they do is they wear like a
rubber band around their wrist and every
time there's no negative pinging
themself remarkable yeah yeah and they
relate to the negativity with that pain
yeah but yeah being positive I mean if
that's if there's one takeaway one habit
that you can have to improve your life
your business property University I'm
gonna add no hostility and go on you
have the client finish my positivity
thing first so one of the ways to do
that is to get negativity out of your
life so I don't watch the news the news
is negative anything that's negative any
films a negativity that I just it
disgusts me I'm like oh I don't want to
see it I wanna know about it so it's
negative get it out your lot people
attracted no negativity you know put a
like looks like Oh gossip oh I I hate it
get it out of your life focus on
positivity and I said about adding years
to your life
scientific fact positive people live on
average eleven years longer then
negative makes optimists live longer
than pessimists I bang on and that leads
us to our final takeaway from today
which I'm going to say don't dwell on
the past so if something's gone wrong
if something's gone wrong in your life
in the property business or something
screwed you over or a deal fell through
or an agent didn't show up or some
things just happen there's been a bit of
a downer forget about it move on
don't don't dwell on it for days and say
oh I'm not going to do that because this
person than that that's their problem
not your problem don't don't make it
your problem and I can't who it was said
this every thought Henry irate I watched
it recently on our video on your
Facebook and it was a guy said look if
you're walking down the street and
somebody's rude to you for like like 10
seconds are you gonna let that root that
about 10 seconds or something being rude
to you ruin your mood for the whole day
and the answer should be no because
that's that person it was rude to use
for it's not your fault it's their
problem so don't make it their problem
so don't dwell on any failures any any
any bad luck or any and it was wrong and
your property business pick yourself up
brush yourself off and move on and suck
it up and get on with it and just don't
don't don't dwell on it do you get
people being rude to you just in general
life no cuz I don't accept that
it's been really I just see them as
ignorant and I just move on I don't
actually accept it because where does it
when does it happen
I like so for instance this morning
getting on the train and the train was
packed and I was stood right at the very
door and there was no one no one I was
getting on this door and some dude come
up to me and tried to push me out the
way and he literally just went he went
like that and I went demand and he went
money to country and I said no you're
not moving me out of the way and I said
I moved on
I don't care he's not good I'm not he's
not gonna affect me I think it's just
he's been an ignorant person couldn't I
couldn't go anywhere so why did he put
man he pushed a weapon he was trying to
make me move I don't know he would try
and poopy sure friends it was didn't one
of you late for walk away ever and he
just he just tried to push everyone and
I'm like Jamar no really yeah and then
he had a bit of go at me and I'm like I
did just choke on man get the next train
and as a door shot really cracked
only time I have people be rude to me
but I'm driving I've been in your car
when you're driving so I understand by
the
anytime not recently law obviously but
no not recently the only time I mean
sometimes like you and they like they V
or whatever sometimes me and they they
put them in forgot me and they leave it
out the window as they're driving away
and I'm live although one guy was
impressed when I overtook him okay and
he was so impressed
he's like entities of my life impressive
overtaking is good how was your driving
gone recently I mean obviously you're
such a good driver had a little go in
your poor surround the car part you did
you could you can't use in a public will
attend you on that bombshell let's move
on this
[Music]
so in the news this week John McDonald
is to declare war and buy two that
landlords by giving tenants the chance
to purchase the property at a discounted
price what a tool
completely not a tool into labor could
give private tenants the right to buy
says John McDonald the right to bias
scheme would see private tenants given
the right to forcibly buy their home a
discounted price by the government do
you know do you know what I'm after tool
why would he do that I'll tell you why I
do that vault season to dinner folks
yeah it was the only reason they're
trying to get votes I'm like thinking is
this gonna be like this like lease
options this is gonna be amazing I mean
all it will do is actually read the
article so let's listen to labor could
give tenants who rent private homes the
right to buy them a cut-price rate the
shuttle at the shallow transfers reveals
gentleman on outline the party's plans
to tackle the burgeoning buy-to-let
market in a bombshell interview last
night the dramatic policy is designed to
clamp down on middle-class families who
buy a second property as a nest egg for
their retirement yet because like how
terrible it can you believe that this
just shows you how the government did
not want you to be successful and the
not one successful rich people the
suggestion from the shadow counselor
applying market factors are calling
right for council tenants to buy their
homes to those who remember operty is
from millions of private landlords
offers a chilling insight into the
consequences of a labor victory in any
snap election and a separate development
report fair mr. McDonald is planning to
confiscate around 300 billion of company
shares and hand them to workers in one
of the biggest stay trades on the
private sector to take place in Western
democracy again what an utter tool yeah
this is like now the new rides by
Erskine was he private asking about
forced to buy their homes blah blah blah
okay cool so that's basically the the
the crux of the
of the article the problem is what the
problem is I'm not worried about it
personally because I'll just buy I mean
for example HMOs how is that gonna work
well they're gonna buy their room yeah
right so what all it's doing me that
would never come it would never come in
it would never ever happen never happen
because there's too many people there's
too many politicians that have many many
properties it would never ever get past
the thing is if it does get passed again
I wouldn't be too bothered because what
would happen is okay they would buy my
by two let's but it's double to buy them
off me so I'll still get the money for
their a discounted price yeah well let's
see what that is when you go back to
council right to buy you could get up to
40% discount what we'll see but from a
property investors point of view
basically just mean we'd have to do
things like service accommodation which
we do anyway yeah
HMOs anyway commercial yes we do anyway
it's I don't really that's not that what
it what's sad about it it's the people
that it won't affect us no won't affect
ours but it is gonna because we'll just
there's there's ways I can is straight
way see loads of ways around it might be
a bit of a pain yeah but it's just gonna
it's just such I mean the government the
education system everything is set up
for everyone everything is designed for
people to be very average yeah I really
it's designed for us too
and who's it this is gonna who's this
going to impact the most if it comes in
which if it's gonna impact people who
have worked hard got a decent job
managed to buy themselves a second home
and instead of squandering their money
instead of gone on holidays and instead
of buying liabilities they went out and
bought the invested their money into an
asset and there's no bed here is trying
to take it off you by giving it some to
a tenant who can get the opportunity to
buy it at this kind of price but what we
need hopefully never never again without
training and stuff we need to show
people how to do it so that this sort
crap isn't isn't going to affect them
and show that you know what they they
can't
yeah we need it you know yeah but the
everyday person every day they should
see you over your every
like parents or whatever that are not
perhaps interim based in but they've
just invested a little bit of money
they've saved up or whatever wisely
they're going to be the ones at fault
not fought but they even the ones that
lose out here because they're not gonna
they're not gonna be able to fight it
they're not going to know what to do
with it so we have to spread the word
about education and try and get them
there we screaming from the rooftops I
can get around it so I mean if it comes
in I don't know if it will but if it
comes in then yeah we need to be yeah we
need to be finding the loopholes and
sharing them with you guys about how to
get around it because it's gonna affect
people but they're the standard
buy-to-let landlord is gay Thompson and
tax it's just like it's emit the anger
every angle they're getting hit by a
baseball bat it's just a shame but there
you go
right it's now time for this okay so
it's time for your questions so here we
go first one well first of all thank you
David a guire just for thanking it's not
a question but thank you for the advice
encourage you give us cheers bro we
appreciate that
Dave William do you think it's a good
time to do a rent to rent and dom cast
of ask before coming in to force my
october this year i'm assuming as you
mentioning article fall that you're
talking about a rent - HM oh yeah rent
rent hit more so yes I'd say it was long
as you can get there is if it needs a
license or not said if it's for bed five
day so it needs a license what needs
converting and article 4 is coming and
your going to need permissions from the
authorities so just make sure that if
you do do it it's complete and up and
running before article 4 is enforced if
you've got to any conversion for
instance or just make sure that that
happens and speak to your local and hm
officer and get their advice on the
legalities of it cool next question from
Maximilian handsome Brooks can you find
and sell deals before you become
compliant legally no you can well yeah
you can you can yeah but it's just
saying can you can you
have a business and not pay taxes yeah
you can yeah you can do whatever you
choose if you get caught you'll get in
trouble
yeah I'm not gonna I'm not gonna condone
it
listen that's your business you got to
do what you got to do I wouldn't advise
it and I wouldn't say yes to it but the
legal answer is you have to be compliant
to introduce any bitterness to our
property our real estate investment cool
okay last one hi guys will the podcast
keep up the great work
alastair yeah oh no sorry keep great
work
Alistair Alistair no no no no hey guys
love the podcast keep up the keep up the
great work
Alistair no it's not what it is it's got
if you would say it there's a thumb like
a stomp it's hey go to the park you'll
do great work Alistair when setting up
deals on to investors who knows your
deal souls yes is there that on top of
the sources well it's a business so yeah
your business is about registered yes if
your business is not about registers no
yeah it depends on your business our
business is about register all off
source and fees are plus VAT and then
also do you then have to pay income tax
on top of that yeah you pay income tax
on or you paid corporation tax on the
business because we look we're a limited
company so we have accountants deal with
all of that so yeah quick what you do
one more yes
hi guys love the show and think you guys
are an awesome crack I beat the crash
course and the DfE in June awesome and
Stuart a renter essay deal in Birmingham
I have a question Matt minimum nights
days and daily rates how do you decide
what to set your rates I mean the night
stays at what price and strategies
should be given with my bed my apartment
is a one-bedroom with very high specs
and a b1 postcode any advice will be
massively appreciate it thank you in
advance you need to get an understanding
of what your competitors are charging
and how you're different to your
competitors so if you're just going to
take a property and it's a little bit it
you see it's a very high standard I
believe you said that
if you're going to think of problems to
a good standard what sets you out from
the competition why would people pay
more for your apartment than somewhere
else so for instance when I'm looking at
staying away i I don't I'm not I don't
I'm not cheapskate
I don't go for the cheapest place so I I
wouldn't when I'm filtering on
, wherever I'm looking I don't do the
automatic cheapest faster and I know
some people do that I look for what
stands out I look for what's nice I look
for what's got the best facilities what
is got facilities I want a parking can I
park my car there
can I pick the keys up if I'm sitting on
a sa can I pick the keys up at the
premises things are out so you just need
to do some market research dude find out
what else is getting charged for and
don't know but it would be to go through
a channel manager cuz they'll advise you
on that as well I mean it's nice and
stuff but quite a lot of people do two
night minimum stays yeah but especially
weekends especially weekend yeah it just
saves you on the cleaning costs and
stuff yeah so yeah awesome hope that
answered your question to a degree got
time for one more
Abram no so we will see you next week on
Saturday at 7 p.m. but thank you ever so
much tuning in see you soon cheers guys
[Music]
[Applause]